right there are two facts about aliens
that
always troubled me about them so one is
that they look too much like us
there's two human in other words but we
just found a way to get around that one
convergent or two they caused us in some
way
and then number two is that the rate of
technological progress should be
should be so far so quick that
they would be unrecognizable there would
be no
through line to even call them aliens
across the decades especially across the
centuries
but you've managed to find a way around
that as well that's fascinating
that's fascinating so now what i'm
wondering i'm sorry to get off on this
idea shooting back and forth no these
are fun things to think about
great great great now what i'm wondering
is imagine if
i have a let's just say a fish tank for
lack of a better word and that fish tank
i can turn up the rate at which
time passes on it so again this is like
that movie analogy it's going at a
trillion times
our speed okay so i'm turning it up what
i want to do is i want to
test out imagine i'm just testing out
how is life going to work in this
scenario
so i can start it maybe it's even
there's a word for this panspermia
yeah right okay so i test out what is
this going to look like then i come back
and i look
what is i wonder if that's what's going
on wonder if we are just some experiment
for them the whole alien abduction
phenomenon is very strange
there's a lot of strange aspects to it
and one thing that
bothers me is that the if the
number of people who claim to be
abducted are if that's actually correct
if they actually have been then
then the question is why and what are
they doing to them because
you don't need to you don't need to
abduct a million people to do a
scientific experiment on
on the human body right you
only need maybe a thousand or so so
way too many people are getting abducted
so the question is what is actually
happening
would be the next question i'd have if
the if the abductions are real of course
right right have you found any credible
evidence to the alien abductions and
have you found any
material that's foreign embedded within
some people i know that some people
claim
no i know that there are is
a group at least one group that is
studying alien abductions in a more
detailed way but that's all that i know
about